mais non merci madame la présidente
madame la Première ministre à l'heure où
je vous parle 30% des stations services
sont à sec je sais votre implication
personnelle depuis plusieurs semaines
pour sortir de ce conflit qui pénalise
l'ensemble des Français à la ville comme
à la campagne encore ce matin c'est une
infirmière qui n'a pas pu aller
prodiguer des soins très attendus par
ses patients c'est un agriculteur qui
est à court de gazole pour faire ses
travaux d'automne c'est un salarié qui
habitait en milieu rural n'a pu
rejoindre son entreprise pour autant les
négociations ont eu lieu entre les
entreprises concernées et les syndicats
certains d'ailleurs ont estimé que les
résultats obtenus étaient satisfaisants
et d'autres blocs encore comme chez
Total malgré un accord majoritaire
quelque part c'est prendre la France et
les Français en otage
comment imaginer que dans une démocratie
une centaine de personnes arrivent ainsi
à bloquer une partie du pays
l'équilibre l'équilibre de nos sociétés
fragiles nous avons besoin d'apaisement
et nous apportons aujourd'hui les
meilleurs réponses possibles le taux
d'inflation en France est le plus bas en
Europe l'État a protégé le pouvoir
d'achat depuis 2020 et les Français le
savent en revanche ce que les Français
ne comprennent pas c'est lorsque les
résultats de leur entreprise parfois
importants ne sont pas réparties
justement et ne bénéficient pas aussi
aux salariés madame la Première ministre
vous avez eu le courage de prendre un
certain nombre de réquisitions ils font
maintenant montrer aux Français que nous
les entendons pour sortir de ce conflit
au plus vite pour rendre à chacun de ce
droit fondamental qui est celui de se
déplacer également pour le rassurer que
ce pays gardera toujours comme boussole
la justice sociale qui assure la
cohésion de notre société et la
préservation de nos talents je vous
remercie
merci